anthony what's this song about these are
the ways i mean um can you give us any
background can you talk about recording
it what can you tell us about this song
so we
so we know something um i can tell you
that that john had
come into a rehearsal early in the
writing process when we were just kind
of getting to know each other again
in a songwriting kind of a way and he
had
he had this beautiful arrangement that
was
different and
it almost felt like a a classical
orchestra because it just kept
crescendoing as the song went further
and really all i had to do is fill in
some lyrical blanks because john had
suggested
uh a lyrical
melody yeah and and sort of an approach
and
and all i do is listen i listen my job
is to listen to what they're playing and
then go drive around in my car and
listen some more and wait until
some words start falling out of the sky
and into their place and then write them
down and kind of refine it a little bit
but it felt like planet earth and the
united states of america in general were
going through a bit of an upheaval
uh
a redefinition of sorts and a
a moment to take a look at ourselves
and see who the hell we had become and
was that okay
so without being heavy-handed or
uh
taking either side i was just like
let's have a look at ourselves right
here this is who we've become and
um it's kind of it's also got a little
bit of
who in it the who i feel like we
we
we channeled the who a little bit
surprised it it became more who-ish but
the initial inspiration for it for me
was the
the sparks album propaganda okay yeah
that's where that makes sense
this is a a song called these are the
ways
[Music]
have we all
had too much
[Music]
lost in a dream
please step down from your bullying
machine can we all
back it up
can we all
give it up
[Music]
i just wanna
yes
[Music]
23 windows and it's gonna be a long ride
pause had enough
have we all
had too
much look how good tide in a basketball
shoes have we all
packed it up
can we all
give it up
[Music]
smells
i don't wanna die and she's gonna take
[Music]
don't
singing
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
you